u.s president joe biden says he's
confronted saudi arabia's crown prince
over the murder of dissident journalist
jamal khashoggi biden is in the kingdom
on a highly anticipated but
controversial visit when he arrived he
bumped fists with muhammad bin salman
the crown prince and de facto leader
biden had refused to speak to him after
khashoggi was killed in a saudi
consulate in 2018. u.s intelligence says
the crown prince approved the killing
a fist bump that has set off a storm of
criticism
u.s president joe biden held talks with
saudi crown prince mohammed bin salman
a man he once promised to make a pariah
over the murder of u.s space journalist
jamal khashoggi
khashoggi's fiancee reacted to the
meeting with a tweet
saying the blood of the prince's next
victim is on biden's hands
the u.s president has countered the
criticism thank you for being here with
respect to the murder of khashoggi i
raised it at the top of the meeting
making it clear what i thought of it at
the time
and what i think of it now he basically
said that he he was not personally
responsible for it i indicated i thought
he was
he said he was not personally
responsible for it and he took action
against those who were responsible
human rights groups worry that this is
far from enough
now saudi arabia has never been a rights
respecting country it's never been a
country where you could speak freely but
what we've seen in the past five years
is a total shutdown of the space for any
public criticism or any hint that you
might disagree with the authorities
the leaders discussions ranged from
regional security to clean energy
initiatives
but saudi oil is being seen as the
driving factor here
especially if it can replace russian
supplies on the global market
the main reason for president biden's
visit to saudi arabia is to attend a
gathering of leaders of nine countries
from the gulf cooperation council
but the meeting that was said to draw
the most scrutiny has already taken
place
well i'm joined now by chincia bianco a
visiting fellow at the european council
on foreign relations based here in
berlin hi chintzya and welcome to dw so
president biden says he believes the
saudi crown prince was responsible for
the murder of jamal khashoggi yet we saw
those images of him fist bumping him so
what does this actually tell us about
the relationship between the u.s and
saudi arabia
well
the relationship between the two
countries
is
rather strained at the moment and the
fact that
the u.s president has decided to
make the crown prince of pariah
because of the killing of german
khashoggi is one of the reasons why
other reasons include the fact that the
u.s has been taking steps back from its
traditional role as a security guarantor
for saudi arabia and for regional
security more largely speaking i think
you know this this meeting is clearly is
a clear indication that that strategy
has uh um all but failed um and that
unfortunately the geopolitical realities
of needing to find energy security uh
and the security of energy prices has
prevailed over human rights
considerations
ginza you've just mentioned that their
energy now the u.s ties with saudi
arabia have essentially been centered on
oil so what is president biden hoping to
achieve on that front
so
since russia invaded ukraine
and we have introduced sanctions on
russian energy we basically have had a
10 million barrel a day large hole in
the market and that has brought energy
prices spiruling out of control as we
know so what then the
various western leaders including u.s
president biden but also boris johnson
uk former prime minister and president
emmanuel macron of france have done to
sort of ease that tight supply is asking
saudi arabia to pump more oil in order
to balance that supply and demand um
question and the saudis so far have
refused and since february they have
refused all calls in this end so what
the president biden hopes to achieve is
that on the 3rd of august when saudi
arabia meets with the other oil
producers including russia they will
decide that they will push themselves
and the other producers to pump more oil
at the end of august thereby easing the
situation from the first of september
cynthia bianco a visiting fellow at the
european council on foreign relations
thank you
thank you very much
well for a market reaction to the
significant visit i want to bring in my
buddy jens corta at the new york stock
exchange hi there jens so we know that
biden is likely to leave saudi without
making a public announcement on the oil
supply but you're there at the exchange
tell us how have markets reacted to his
visit
yeah chrissie there have not been any
commitments but there have been some
remarks from joe biden after the meeting
and he said he's doing everything within
his power to make sure to increase
demand in the united states well i mean
he can't force the private companies
here to do so but that's at least his
intention to try everything possible if
you look at saudi arabia that's a bit
different the crown prince theoretically
could order to just pump their oil more
oil if that's technically possible
there's a lot of
guessing if
saudi arabia could increase production
even if they
wanted to so no real commitment but at
least some intention to increase
production on both ends the oil price
actually did increase a bit in
the friday
session for the week oil is down by
about seven percent but that's not
because of the meeting but because of
global recession fears
okay yeah and so we know that uh oil and
energy is obviously a major factor
playing into the u.s and the global
economy right now uh we also saw second
quarter financial results for banks out
this week can you tell us what did those
results uh say about where the economy
is headed
yeah sure i mean so far we've gotten the
numbers from jp morgan for instance the
biggest bank in the united states or
from citigroup on friday and what those
banks have in common that obviously
they're looking at quite some headwind
that's why they're putting money aside
for a possible
credit
losses in the hundreds of millions and
dollars and that is dragging a profit
down at this point so all the banks so
far um have announced a pretty steep
profit decrease they're still profitable
but not as possible profitable as they
were before it was anyhow interesting to
see on friday city beating estimates on
wall street the stock was up by a
stunning 13 and now on monday the bank
earnings continue with the numbers from
bank of america and goldman sachs but i
expect a similar story
thanks for that yens we'll check in with
you on monday
you